hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
we're back I'm flooring it and today is
Thursday it's dead stream recap today
but there really wasn't much to talk
about it was about some of the feedback
from the open test the new recognition
emote which I'll be talking about a
little bit and the double xp fest and
stuff like that so let's get started
with today's video so as I said in the
beginning there's going to be a double
xp fest on all orders and game lows this
weekend so play your main character and
rank that character up or if you've
never played a certain character and you
just want some rank then just play with
them either way it's completely fine and
the next one Wednesday there's also
going to be a 30% off discount on all
steal packs in the store if you want to
buy them as well and on top of that dual
tournament it's also going to be coming
back this weekend so if you are a big
fan of dual tournament you can go play
that if you want next up is the content
of the week and the emote is gonna be
called recognition for all heroes but it
is a different emo it's a hero specific
emo meaning it's different for every
four on her character and it's an emote
to show respect to your opponent once
you defeat them not being biased but
gladiator has the best emo in my opinion
because he has the entire crowds war
behind him when he does it and I cannot
wait to make a video on this so expect
that coming up and then a couple hours
after this video has been uploaded I'll
show some gameplay of that next they
talked about the open test results and I
went really well to dev still want to
improve so that most matches and the
King phase so that the game can go
longer and just overall improving the
bots and of course the overall balance
as well just make sure things aren't
unbalanced in any situation that being
ticket count BOTS or just matches in
general I have been in situations where
we destroyed the gate and we were going
to go to the King next and then we went
from four tickets to eight tickets which
is horrible and clearly it wasn't enough
and we ended up losing the game that
stuck feedback on the new heroes and
planned on tweaking all of them if not
most of them on the Wulin faction and
all upgrade prices are not going to be
20% off when marching fire releases so
you could figure out your favorite build
for Perks and they'll have to waste a
lot of Steel for it and it feels bad man
for many Raiders because obviously a
greater had a slight change in the open
test obviously he had a side heavy on a
guard break but that also had some
faster timings because his moves aren't
in like the hundreds like they're
usually our most character's moves are
400 500 or 600 milliseconds but they
wanted to experiment with more smaller
numerals ended up going with 566 866 so
smaller millisecond numbers more precise
numbers so sadly that was just the test
for
other heroes so it's actually not coming
into the game just yet it was just a
test to see how it would work with
Raider and he was the kind of a
scapegoat for that or the test dummy
hopefully they still keep the side heavy
off GB but lower the damage a bit
because I know that if they get rid of
that GB Raider mains will be furious
everywhere yeah guys let me know your
thoughts about all this stuff in the
comments below specifically let me know
your favorite recognition emo if you
think that you know your main has a
better one or just a specific character
in general Heisman like I said I'll
Dobie in the background if the video is
not done by now I will have them being
played in the background until the end
of the video but anyway guys think guys
for watching the elective if you do
enjoy a subscriber for new I cover the
informational side of foreign of that
being balance changes hero updates patch
notes at leaks news all that good stuff
I mean that guy's two most recent videos
will be on screen if you guys do want to
check that out and that guy's hope with
great yesterday they can watch the video
and peace out
[Music]